so my goal my priority since the start
of the coronavirus pandemic has
been to be accurately alarmist for the
information that we have and there was a
period
back in i think it was december january
where i was getting emails from people
saying david you're overly alarmist this
isn't going to be anything
and then there was maybe a little period
sort of like in may
where i was maybe more optimistic about
the situation
than some in the audience but i i think
that i've done an
okay job at more or less accurately
communicating the sort of status of the
situation and the outlook with the
pandemic
and i have what i think is some
accurately
but cautiously optimistic news for you
today
and although the timing of it is
interesting this is not a political
comment
but there is a mathematical coincidence
pointing to
um a case and death peak
hopefully the last one of the pandemic
right around the time of joe biden's
inauguration now
i'm not making a political segment out
of this it's mere coincidence when we
i'll show you the math
and the trajectories but it seems as
though right around january 20th the day
that joe biden will be sworn in
as president that we will be starting
to get past what is hopefully the last
peak
of this pandemic and again it's a
coincidence i'm not claiming january
20th
joe biden will be sworn in and covid
will be fixed it is
merely a timing coincidence and we know
that these peaks
depend on what happens in the weeks and
months leading up
but i want to go through it with you
because it does feel like we're starting
to get
into the tunnel at least we're maybe
seeing the light or maybe not but we're
definitely
in the part of the tunnel that we would
consider the latter part of the tunnel
now as you
may know we've had three coronavirus
peaks in the united states
many countries have only had two we've
had three first one was in april
second one was in july and the third one
is right now
and in this third peak we've seen cases
spike all the way up to close to 250 000
cases in a single day
mostly in the low 200s 210 215
000 and what you can also see when
looking at the case graph
if you're watching along with me today
is that over the last 10 days
the rate of case growth has slowed down
meaning the curve flattened and it even
turned downwards in the last few days
now it is quite possible that there's
still
one more peak to go fueled by holiday
and
end of year travel and indoor gatherings
we shouldn't do them
it's sort of a foregone conclusion that
no matter what i say many people are
going to do them but
the rate of case growth in the u.s at a
at a large broad level
is slowing down looking at the
predictions in the models from a variety
of epidemiologists and other experts the
case
peak is expected to be right around the
end of this
of the first week of january you know
january 7 8 9 10 11 12.
very rough estimate and we know that
deaths lag
cases by about three weeks and when you
look at the deaths chart right now you
see a similar pattern to cases
and while in this third peak we've
started to see
the cases come down a bit we are only
seeing the growth of death slow down so
we we likely are about three weeks
behind in terms of deaths where we are
in cases so
if we see a case peak around call it
january 10th
to pick a date we would expect to see a
death peak right around february 1.
in all likelihood and this doesn't
justify getting careless
it doesn't do anything to change the
tragic death and destruction that the
virus has already brought to date but
in all likelihood that in january
will be the final peak of this pandemic
unless something dramatic changes
why because that will not only be the
worst moment in terms of weather and
people being indoors
december january is the coldest time of
the year
in the parts of the u.s that have winter
but as the temperature warms and the
days get longer and people spend more
time outside
we will also have the benefit of the
vaccination program vaccination has
started in the u.s
we have the approved vaccine from pfizer
emergency use approval
second vaccine from moderna expected to
be approved for emergency use tomorrow
third vaccine may be in the first
quarter of the new year so at the same
time that we will be peaking in cases
and deaths with the coldest weather and
the most people indoors
we will have if all goes to plan all
health care workers vaccinated by
february 1st
all nursing home residents vaccinated by
february 1st and we will be in the
process of vaccinating
that next most vulnerable group which
will include the oldest folks and those
with the most serious comorbidities and
by protecting an additional five to
seven percent of the population each
month
starting now going into january february
march
that peak we're expecting in january is
likely to be the final one and have a
more rapid decline than without
vaccination so this is all excellent
news
but there is still a big battle here
we're still going to have to do all the
things we've been
many of us have been doing not all of us
masks
social distancing avoiding indoor
gatherings
but it is mathematically looking like
we're potentially about
three weeks from the case peak of the
pandemic
and five to six weeks from the death
peak and at that point
the vaccination program will be more
robust with millions of vaccinations
weekly so there is a light there
that's the good news now given this
we should be extra cautious in these
next months because we're so close it's
not like
listen this is going to go on for two or
three more years
and we might be well uh for
psychological reasons maybe we take a
screw it attitude and just have a good
time
starting now we will see five ish
percent of the country vaccinated each
month that's huge
and we are close to deaths and and cases
starting to decline
so the message is that's the math of it
those are the expectations that's where
vaccination is
we're just a couple months away from
significantly better circumstances
my friends so let's do everything that
we can
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently checked
out the book podcast marketing strategy
by daniel rolls and kieran rogers
and so useful so particularly applicable
to what i'm doing
really recommend it blinkist has books
on politics philosophy science they have
27 different non-fiction categories and
a subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video